Jason I understand you have an
interesting story on how you got
involved the short film cuddle yes I you
know that was my first short film for
some reason short when I hear short film
I think these are things that people are
gonna make and they're nothing's ever
gonna come of it and I'm somebody who I
don't like to do things on spec I like
to do things for people to see but I was
connected through somebody a prince a
potter young because I guess the actor
that they had the probably you know
good-looking actor that they had big
thing it was some kind of drama with
with this person it's not for me to say
what it is you can ask and Lily about
that so I was brought in very very last
minute and you know they sent me the
script and just like script you know I'm
an improviser you know that's how I got
started and everything doing improv live
live improv and sketch comedy so I sent
the script I glanced at it didn't even
you know didn't even read it really and
then showed up for like a table reading
they're like you know what do you think
I was like ah this is great really love
it not hardly read it but I think just
on the on the kind of suggestion of
somebody I trusted I was like yeah why
don't I do it why don't I do a short
film and I you know realized that mica
tan who's in it whose absolutely I you
know I really think she really she makes
it she's an adult star and you know I've
been doing a you know podcast with adult
stars so I'm like it's you know it's
just like written in the stars that I
have to do and it's in the premise is
great I remember looking online this
world of cuddlers and I was like this is
the most interesting thing I've seen in
a long time like truly interesting thing
subculture thing that I've seen in a
long time
so then I was just I showed up and then
we just we just did it and and I was
like great I'm doing a doing I'm doing a
really cool short film which I'd never
done before
you